[Музика]
привіт, мене звати Наталія, і це
зроблено для нашого уроку англійської мови, я сподіваюся, що
ви всі здорові та щасливі, тому що
ми знаємо, що нам для цього потрібно, ми потребуємо
Спорт і смачна їжа, давайте поговоримо про
спорт, перш ніж почати  після уроку я хотів
би, щоб ми побачили, чого ми навчилися
в попередніх, звичайно, ми пройшли
через багато різних видів спорту, як-от
легка атлетика, екстремальні види спорту,
командні види спорту на відкритому повітрі та інші
Я впевнений, що ви вже знаєте, як
користуватися  грай і займайся спортом ми говорили
про найпопулярніший вид спорту у
світі футбол
зараз ти можеш я сподіваюся, що ти можеш
пояснити, чому ти любиш той чи інший вид спорту
і навіть трохи поговорити про свій спортивний
досвід, хороші чи погані голи попереду
граматика з модальними дієсловами і у вас
було домашнє завдання, давайте перевіримо,
ваше домашнє завдання полягало в тому, щоб заповнити
речення модальними дієсловами.
це правило
закодованих 19 футболістів не повинні торкатися
м'яча це заборонено ми повинні надягати
маски, коли заходимо в магазин так це
також правило з
періоду призупинення ви не повинні пірнати в
басейн це небезпечно ми використовуємо тут не повинні
тому що це заборонено це небезпечно
і останній ви не можете прийти сюди
без документів це заборонено
, тому ми використовуємо can't okay,
а як щодо вашого власного спорту, що щодо
цього варіанту бігати книги це означає, що
ви можете бігати, читаючи книги  або
з купою книжок добре,
чому б ні, і перед тим, як ми розпочнемо новий
урок, давайте спочатку перевіримо ваше
завдання правильно ці помилки не
бійтеся робити помилки, тому що всі
роблять їх добре речення номер один ми можемо
грати в хокей у воді так  це
помилка, що ми не можемо грати в хокей у
воді
люди повинні палити в кафе ні ніколи
це заборонено жінка не може стати
президентом України це також помилки
тому що жінка може добре дивитися кабінки
це правильний варіант  e і ми йдемо далі і
давайте трохи рухаємося я хочу, щоб ви повторювали
за мною деякі рухи це дуже легко я
роблю це зі своїми дітьми це легко добре повторюйте
за мною
голова і плечі очі і вуха очі
і вуха повільно дуже повільно
голова і плечі очі  і вуха очі
і вуха повільно голова і плечі очі
і вуха а тепер швидко голова і
плечі eysan
очі і вуха голова і плечі очі
і вуха очі і вуха чудово добре ми
зробили це повільно і ми зробили це швидко і
це тема нашого уроку  прислівники
прислівники розповідають нам, як відбулася дія, як
щось відбувається, описує
дієслово, тому він викликає дієслово add, це
додає щось до дієслова ми можемо зробити це
дуже легко з прикметників slow plus ly
will be slowly так прикметники slow and
slowly прислівник quick adjective plus  ly
буде прислівником швидко дуже легко, але у
нас є деякі неправильні прислівники, як-от boot
як об'єктивний, а також прислівник і
hast будуть такими ж, як прикметник
і прислівник швидко, швидко також важко важко і
l  ate late
пам'ятайте, що дієприслівник завжди йде після
дієслова, оскільки він описує прислівник,
наприклад, she runs slowly slowly йде
після дієслова runs, тому що він описує це
вона повільна бігунка повільна в цьому
реченнях є прикметником
це описує слово she that's all about
прикметники як a  правила, а тепер давайте
потренуємося, давайте вправляти нашу англійську Brehme,
тому що англійську ви знаєте так само, як і
в спорті, вам потрібно багато тренуватися, щоб бути
кращим.
дієслово sink
moly sings співає голосно ми змінюємо його та
використовуємо прислівник loudly good давайте зробимо це
друге, як ви його зміните Джек
і Лео хороші тенісисти ваш
варіант так Чет і Лео добре грають в теніс,
тому що прислівник від good will be
well next  Я швидко бігаю слово
бігати, як ти це зміниш так, я швидко бігаю,
буде так само, як
прикметник і прислівник next просто їсть
здорову їжу їж, як ти це зміниш, в
основному його  здоров'я дурно так молодець
Міллі і останнє речення деякі
тварини дуже повільно рухаються деякі тварини
рухаються повільно гарне слово а тепер подивіться на
цю картинку ви можете побачити зайця і
черепаху як ви думаєте хто бігає
повільно хто повільно так звичайно
черепаха  але я хотів би, щоб ви
послухали історію «Черепаха та заєць»,
написану стародавнім письменником, перш
ніж ви послухаєте цю історію, давайте
пройдемося деякими
лексиками.  шанувальник, що лесбіянка його
поза полем зору через затримку спричинила
зміну, продовжуй продовжити виробництво
з проблемами, пов'язаними з глузуванням або
смішити nazma katisa, щоб подрімати
більш гладка техніка вчить e наздоганяти нас
Dejan yachty у мене є друг її
звати Саша і вона живе у
Великобританії, вона прочитає цю історію для вас,
тому що вона любить читати іноді вона
сама пише історії страшні історії,
але ця історія не страшна слухайте мене
новини про  Саша так Yahoo профінансував
Геродота лінивцем-зайцем, який
одного дня насміхався над Черепахою за
те, що вона така повільна, чи ти коли-небудь потрапиш куди-небудь, куди
він насміхався,
відповіла черепаха, і я доберуся
швидше, ніж ти
думаєш.  Я проведу вас у перегонах і доведу, що
зайця дуже потішила ідея
пробігти перегони з черепахою, але
заради розваги він погодився, тому
Лисиця не відстань і почав
бігунів від зайця незабаром зникла з
поля зору
щоб висміяти черепаху за те, що вона намагалася
бігти із зайцем, він ліг біля
курсу, щоб подрімати, черепаха
тим часом продовжувала йти повільно, але невпинно
і через деякий час пройшла повз місце,
де спала шерсть, але заєць
спав дуже спокійно і коли в  востаннє він
прокинувся черепаха була біля мети,
заєць зараз біг найшвидше, але він
не зміг наздогнати морально повільно й стабільно
виграє гонку
Дякую, Саша, щоб ти міг
знову послухати історію заєць
черепаха заміною зайця  хто був
одного разу насміхатися над черепахою за те, що вона така повільна, чи
ти коли-небудь кудись потрапиш,
глузуючи сміючись, так відповіла черепаха,
і я приїду раніше, ніж ти думаєш,
я проведу тобі перегони і доведу, що
зайця дуже весело  ідея
бігти з черепахою, але
заради розваги він погодився, тому
Лис не віддалявся від дистанції й кинув
бігунів від зайця незабаром зникла з
поля зору, щоб висміяти черепаху, яку ми
намагаємося бігти із зайцем, він  лягла
поруч, щоб подрімати, черепаха
тим часом йшла повільно, але невпинно
і через деякий час пройшла місце,
де спало волосся, але заєць
спав дуже спокійно, і коли він нарешті
прокинувся, черепаха була біля
мети.  зараз заєць побіг найшвидшим, але він
не зміг наздогнати
Морель повільно і стабільно виграє гонку, але
тепер скажи мені, що Жахливо, заєць
насміхався над черепахою, це правда, так,
заєць насміхався над черепахою, що
вона така
повільна  два заєць як  попросив
черепаху бігти з ним, ні, це неправда,
тому що це черепаха попросила
брати участь у перегонах з ним з її номером
три. Лисиця розпочала бігуни,
люди почали перегони так, це правда
номер чотири черепаха тукан,
крім траси  звичайно, ні, це
неправда, це волосся, яке потрібно підключити,
крім курсу, і останнє - це
волосся виграло гонку
ні в якому разі це історія про те, як повільна
тварина, як черепаха, виграла гонку, добре,
а тепер давайте заповнимо ці пропуски
новими фразами  далеко поза полем зору
Лейкерс холодно продовжують тренування,
що тринова Тіса висміює це я,
Хадасса, я когось наздоганяю Mazda
Hinata,
тому перше речення, якщо ви хочете бути
кращим у спорті чи вивченні англійської, у
вас є свій варіант так  продовжуйте
тренування номер два, це не ввічливо
знущатися над однокласниками, тому що це
знущання, це не ввічливо сміятися так,
номер три, він біг дуже швидко, тому
незабаром він зник із поля зору, він був дуже
файним  r і останній не їде так швидко,
я не можу вас наздогнати добре відмінно,
а тепер давайте подивимося речення з
цього тексту з прикметниками та прислівниками,
де речення з прислівником так
номер два і номер три черепаха
тим часом продовжувала йти  повільно, але неухильно
Пауліно Едіт Піаф нонотук непальський рівень,
це, до речі, причина, чому вона
виграла номер три, але заєць спав на
дуже мирно спав там,
мирно мирно, це прислівник, і
це причина, чому волосся не виграли
гонку, тому що  він добре спав, то
чому черепаха виграла гонку, подумай про це
і вислови свою думку, якщо ти хочеш
висловити свою думку, то ти повинен використовувати
ці фрази, я думаю, тому що я думаю, що, як
я вірю, це те саме значення, яке я думаю,
на мою думку  я або це тому, що
ці фрази допоможуть вам висловити
свою думку, можливо, ви згодні чи не згодні
з моєю думкою, ви можете використовувати ці фрази,
я згоден з вами або я бачу, що ви маєте на увазі
, ви повинні мені порадитися  ing
or you've got a point
yeah, you - right sure I don't
see the option in
response press Maura Я не бачу це таким чином Джонні
бюджетує в Kimchi no II, і я не
дуже згоден, так
Сік Napo закип’ятити, щоб використовувати ці
фрази. Я хотів би, щоб ви запропонували
невеликий діалог між двома особами про
біг підтюпцем, давайте разом вставимо ці
слова в рослини добре, я збираюся бігати
, ви хочете приєднатися до мене
ні, дякую, я не бачу  їх так, я не
бачу сенсу
Janna мій Oh Neuros доповнення місяця
вправи дуже важливі їсти так
тримати вас на ногах і допомагає вам це
причина, чому це важливо, я розумію, що ви
маєте на увазі, так, ви маєте рацію
мої очі тепер бачите, але для мене
біг підтюпцем нудний я не дуже згоден я
не дуже згоден, добре бути
на вулиці так, свіже повітря,
чому б вам не спробувати, добре, тоді
я спокійний, це  дух
ні, це інтерес Браво, ці
підкреслені слова ми використовуємо, щоб висловити свою
думку, і давайте щось зробимо  вправи зі
словами більше вправ мовні вправи
ви знаєте, що ми можемо створити програвач
слів із гри слів, а потім закінчуючи ER та ER
дуже легко, коли ми плюс
ми закінчуємо Proteas, у нас є
людина, яка це робить, наприклад
гра  гравець jump jumper та решту
цих слів зробіть самі, і давайте перевіримо,
що у вас є так
стрибун плавець ковзанин серфінг тренер і
переможець що ще ми можемо створити з
протестного реквізиту від дієслова
плавання назва протестів завжди назва
спорту, наприклад  плавати плавати бігати
бігати стрибати та виконайте решту цих
слів самостійно
добре, давайте перевіримо, у нас є ці слова
стрибки ковзання серфінг бокс їзда на велосипеді
дайвінг усі ці порти, які ми використовуємо з яким
дієсловом грати go або do yes з go go
плавати go running go jumping go
skating  молодці в кінці нашого
уроку. Я б хотів, щоб ви запропонували своє
домашнє завдання,
це про прислівник, ви повинні розкрити
гальма, використовуючи прислівники в цих реченнях
це домашнє завдання, яке ви можете знайти  на YouTube
під цим відео також ці три
фотографії, які ви можете використовувати для створення власного
виду спорту, використовуйте свою уяву, і чи чули ви
коли-небудь про цей вид спорту, чи знаєте ви,
що це можливо, це незвичайний вид спорту,
який насправді поєднує волейбол,
батут, стрибки, стрибки, стрибки
на  пляж з музикою, добре,
можливо, і давайте подивимося, що ми
сьогодні навчилися, ми дізналися, що
таке прислівник і як його використовувати, ми
послухаємо байку s up про черепаху
та зайця,
і тепер ми знаємо, що якщо ми хочемо  щоб
бути кращим у спорті або англійською, нам потрібно
продовжувати тренуватися, продовжувати,
ми повинні не зупинятися, і ми повинні наполегливо працювати,
і тепер ви знаєте, як висловити
свою думку, використовуючи фрази, ці фрази, які
ви також можете знайти у відео  на
YouTube, тож будьте здорові та щасливі,
дякую і до побачення
[Музика].